[Music]
next morning and I'm up at dawn to
report for duty with the sausage queen
[Music]
like most of Thailand
mrs. Rudd is a Buddhist today she's
preparing a feast for a traditional
house blessing given by monks from the
local temple puts me straight to work
making the centerpiece of the feast a
classic spicy pork curry called hung Lai
mrs. Rhoades recipe starts with the same
foundation as nearly every authentic
Thai dish that's the secret they're a
really good curry paste and it seems to
be the start of everything this is an
important recipe to add to my Thai
repertoire
a cheap but tasty cut of pork goes in
okay then cane sugar dark soy and a
touch of tamarind whether missing the
run liked or not
I'm determined to learn every bit of
this recipe excuse me sweet pea always
had no secrets she's just stuck the
ginger in there you've got to tell me so
I can soak and follow this
we promise no secrets she says you're
gonna steal her the recipe I'm not gonna
steal them
but mrs. Rhoades recipe is a great
inspiration delicious rich sweet sour is
very fragrant as well and they've got a
real cheap cut the pork in there but
it's just starting to melt absolute
delicious the guests of honor have
arrived to bless the house they take all
the bad spirit have the house yeah it's
out because really like to leave with a
peaceful happiness
[Music]
[Music]
it's fascinating and a real privilege to
be here
but I can't sit around enjoy myself I
got work to do started nudging me tell
him to get back downstairs
time to finish off the dish so you don't
argue with her that's for sure
these monks survive solely on food
they're given but I wonder if they'll
approve of my donation the man says is
delicious that's a great privilege for
me to be here and to give you the chance
to cook for them I don't think they know
who I am they don't wash - sorry - it's
kitchen nightmare
this seems like a good moment to make a
great escape and visitor okay thank you
so you put your arm around there and do
them around there that's it and then
squeeze tight and squeeze excellency
wasn't that bad
thank you so much thank you
delicious excellent good bye
unbelievable
up north has been amazing what I'm
discovering a new new textures new
fragrant flavors like I've never had
before which is refreshing and the
interesting thing for me is that there's
so much more to Thai curries than just a
red and a green and it all starts with
that amazing paste